[Music]  Hey  [Music]  today losers yo with a tech rosette  Brian Dundee yep really yeah really  how do you keep saying really mean done  days lost in the outback he is the other  you know everybody talks about Mick like  that definitely that North might should  stop nice  how big  you mean his - you ever seen a humpback  whale give birth to bloodbath  speak to me little guy well my dad told  me about this he was just like yeah I  just came up and you did they bit there  this okay I just don't think you can see  you from back here  I don't just on this newspaper son I in  this country and dundies gonna learn who  the most dangerous animal in Australia  is it's me whatever  [Music]  my mom's side of the family are all jazz  musicians so kind of comes naturally  [Music]  wombat  you